I've just chaired a meeting of the
government's Emergency Committee Cobra
following the stick and depraved
terrorist attack on the streets of our
capital this afternoon the full details
of exactly what happened are still
emerging but having been updated by
police and security officials I can
confirm that this appalling incident
began when a single attacker drove his
vehicle into pedestrians walking across
Westminster Bridge killing two people
and injuring many more including three
police officers this attacker who was
armed with a knife then ran towards
Parliament where he was confronted by
the police officers who keep us and our
democratic institutions safe tragically
one officer was killed the terrorist was
also shot dead the United Kingdom's
threat level has been set at severe for
some time and this will not change
Acting Deputy Commissioner Rowley will
give a further operational update later
this evening our thoughts and prayers go
out to all who have been affected to the
victims themselves and their family and
friends who waved their loved ones off
but will not now be welcoming them
for those of us who were in Parliament
at the time of this attack these events
provide a particular reminder of the
exceptional bravery of our police and
security services who risk their lives
to keep us safe once again today these
exceptional men and women ran towards
the danger even as they encouraged
others to move the other way on the
heart of the whole country I want to pay
tribute to them and to all our emergency
services for the work they have been
doing to reassure the public and bring
security back to the streets of our
capital city that they have lost one of
their own in today's attack only makes
their calmness and professionalism under
pressure all the more remarkable the
location of this attack was no accident
the terrorists wrote chose to strike at
the heart of our capital city where
people of all nationalities religions
and cultures come together to celebrate
the values of liberty democracy and
freedom of speech these streets of
Westminster home to the world's old
oldest Parliament are ingrained with a
spirit of freedom that echoes in some of
the farthest corners of the globe and
the values our Parliament represents
democracy freedom human rights the rule
of law command the admiration and
respect of free people everywhere that
is why it is a target for those who
reject those values but let me make it
clear today as I have had cause to do
before any attempt to defeat those
values through violence and terror is
doomed to failure tomorrow morning
Parliament will meet
as normal we will come together as
normal and Londoners and others from
around the world who have come here to
visit this great city will get up and go
about their day as normal they will
board their trains they will leave their
hotels they will walk these streets they
will live their lives and we will all
move forward together never giving in to
terror and never allowing the voices of
hate and evil to drive us apart